you
you know scientists have tried for
decades to find something wrong with
caffeine and they can't no matter how
hard they try we metabolize caffeine
some of us metabolize it better than
others I happen to be a fast metabolizer
so it doesn't affect me at all unless I
have really a lot of it but for people
who are sensitive to caffeine they know
it they know that if they eat something
that's got caffeine in it they get jumpy
and shaky and they don't like the way it
feels so they cut back on it but if
you're not really consuming huge
quantities it doesn't have very much of
it in fact I don't think it's so good
for kids and certainly teachers in
school complain a lot that if the kids
are highly caffeinated they're bouncing
off the walls and it makes it harder for
the kids to concentrate and harder for
them to do their work so that would be
the main thing but what really bothers
me about it is it's not labeled I think
it ought to be labeled on food products
and on drinks so then people have a
choice right now they don't have a
choice
energy and food comes from protein fat
and carbohydrate any food with protein
fat or carbohydrate will give you energy
you want fast energy than that's
carbohydrates rapidly absorbable
carbohydrates or sugars but all foods
give you energy that's what calories
about are about that's why you have to
eat if you need energy and the nutrients
that go with it